you
[Music]
anytime Waterloo reminiscing for the
time so thank you all for coming
it's really a pleasure to be hosting dr.
Jesse Howie here at Microsoft Reiser
Montreal
so dr. Howie is as some of you may know
an associate professor in the David art
Chariton school of computer science at
the you know say Waterloo where he leads
the computational human intelligence
laboratory he holds a PhD from the
University British Columbia has
published over a hundred peer-reviewed
scientific papers and has received a
number of awards including from
Microsoft have to talk about that one
the AAI and the International
Association for pattern recognition and
he's also also for the American
Sociological Association and I think he
may be one of the only computer
scientists that I know of who has two
articles in the American Sociological
review which is the best sociological
review in States possibly the world so
he's very discipline or disciplinary
he's an area chair for the International
joint conference on our initial into
artificial intelligence and was the
program chair and the tenth eai
international conference on pervasive
computing and he'll be speaking today on
social and emotional artificial
intelligence so please welcome dr.
Hawaii thanks Luke and thanks for
inviting me here and hosting me at this
visit so much really is my hometown so I
was always nice to come back here and
see how things have changed a little bit
so I'm gonna yeah I talked to you about
artificial intelligence but my
perspective on it might be a little bit
different than kind of the mainstream
view of AI these days but I'll start
with this slide with some some pictures
of some of the big some big achievements
in AI so obviously artificial
intelligence has come a long way from
computers that could beat chess
grandmasters this is quite a while ago
now - you know self-driving cars and
computers that can play much more
challenging games nowadays but one of
the things if we look at artificial
intelligence in group behavior then the
situation looks a little bit different
so this is a picture from the 2017
Robocop which is
probably the quintessential sort of
multi agent problem and these robots are
you know are playing on a team and so it
is sort of funny because they're the
robots in there they're a little bit
difficult to maintain the you know
standing and things like that but they
do know that they're playing on a team
and they probably have some kind of
centralized controller but they really
have no notion of what being a team
member means right and what that what
they essentially they lack is any kind
of idea of empathy or culture emotion or
altruism so they don't have a way of
kind of interpreting what other agents
are how other agents are handling the
situation as team members as a social
group and there has been some efforts to
make this happen so let's try to put
some emotional behaviors into our robots
so here's this guy who's he's happy and
now he's not so happy maybe he'd let in
a goal or something like that but of
course these are just purely scripted
behaviors right this robot has no idea
what this means to any other robot and
in fact no other robot has any other way
of interpreting these signals okay and
if you look at humans when they play
games together you see this vast array
of emotions going on so this is a short
clip from that this is the the barsa
junior team that just beat this this
Korean team you can see this incredible
array of emotions going on and different
cultural signals that they're sending to
each other like this guy is using the
face slap which must be some kind of
Spanish yeah you know expression of of
empathy I'm not sure it works so well
with these Korean guy there he's trying
to show
so anyways so so the bottom line is that
artificial intelligence has come a long
way and we can do some remarkable things
with it but when we get to the point
where AI or robots or artificial
intelligence systems are trying to
interact with humans or with groups of
humans the situation looks quite
different and so this is sort of a
well-known problem if you look at
self-driving cars for example
self-driving cars have some difficulty
when they get to busy intersections for
example and one of the reasons that they
have difficulty is that they can't
display enough aggression to get through
the intersection right so this cartoon
by the oatmeal is meant to sort of
Lampoon that a little bit and this is a
situation where this Google car is
trying to negotiate passage with this
human through an intersection and you've
probably all been in this situation
where you don't know who's gonna go next
and and somebody has got to kind of take
the bull by the horns and kind of drive
forward and that aggression level is a
culturally determined thing so if you go
to different cultures people have
different ways of doing it right and so
in this situation the the humans like
making this way too complicated and the
robot has has no idea of what's going on
the bottom line is that these robots
these self-driving cars have no model of
how a human works okay so they have no
human model in them they have models of
how things move in the world but they
don't have a model of something like the
level of aggression that's needed to get
through an intersection so artificial
intelligence has taken a stab at putting
emotions into artificial intelligence
systems and this is sort of coined this
there's a term that's used to describe
this is effective computing so here I
have a picture I don't know why I put
Vaughn know I'm in there but anyways
there he is and he didn't work on
emotion so much but herb Simon was
probably the first person to think
seriously about what you know how could
you put emotions into a machine and you
know what what would that mean
and he basically described emotions as
being something that disrupts cognition
right so we're thinking all these
high-level thoughts and we're reasoning
about what to do next and then emotions
come in and sort of kind of disrupt
everything but the the the disruption is
there for a reason right it's Abel's us
to better coordinate with other human
beings for example and then Ross Picard
wrote the book I guess wrote the book on
effective computing 1997 and the book
starts with this quote this book
proposes that we give computers the
ability to recognize Express and in some
cases have emotions is this not absurd
right so in 1997 this was you know
nobody had really thought this before
written it down and it did seem very
absurd but she was a professor at MIT so
she could get away with saying absurd
things I guess and since then the field
has grown and which is now in I Triple E
transactions on effective computing and
there's a couple of major conferences so
there's is a fair bit of work in in the
area and Ross Picard gave a talk at
triple AI in 2017 describing some of her
amazing work on using wearables to
detect emotions for healthcare
applications and they've really done
some amazing things in in doing that but
if you look at artificial intelligence
so for example in the 2017 Triple A I I
looked through all of the titles when
she was giving this talk and found the
word emotion appeared three times right
that's three times in about a thousand
papers and the same thing in 2018 and so
I sort of feel like this this study of
emotions has sort of been pushed a
little bit to the side by a lot of the
recent developments in in a time but
it'll make a comeback okay so I think
that the the view that herb Simon
proposed which has sort of been largely
what a lot of effective computing has
worked from that emotions are sort of
disruptors of cognition I think that
this may actually be fundamentally
backwards and I'll try to explain why
and then I'm going to
in this talk a model that I think puts
the cart before the sari puts the horse
before the cart instead of the cart
before the horse and so I'll try to
motivate it with some evidence that we
have from neural physiology so this is a
very very highly stylized picture of
what's going on in the human brain and
from this paper by shoe and they guard
and what they do is they describe two
different systems that happen in human
cognition and they call it a low road
and a high road and the low road is
something that is these are both
cognitive processes so these are not
instinctive things these are actually
things that humans reason about but the
low road is something that takes sort of
avoids the large parts of the sensory
cortex and is something that happens
very very quickly and is able to give
human beings a rough idea of what to do
next okay then the high road is a
pathway through the brain that takes
longer but then it goes through this
because these cortical reasoning aspects
and that's where you do your actual sort
of cognitions and thinking about you
know how the world works and so on and
so forth the interplay between these two
systems is really quite an interesting
part of how humans make decisions and
act in the world with again this low
road sort of providing this very fast
sort of quick and dirty solutions to
things and this high road coming in
later if necessary and kind of trying to
fix things up right you see the same the
same idea of two systems coming out from
psychology and behavioral economics so
perhaps the most famous example of this
is this book by Daniel Kahneman Thinking
Fast and Slow where he describes these
two systems again the fast system one
which operates automatically and quickly
and then the slow system two which is
effortful mental activity in complex
calculations and the way that they work
together in Kahneman's were
or what he's just how he describes it is
that the system one is the thing it is
always in operation that humans are
using to get by and then when that runs
into trouble people call this system too
into play in order to help them figure
out what to do right but people do not
want to go and use this system to
because it takes more energy yeah if you
can avoid using it might as well you get
by with much less if you can go with
this and you see the same idea
throughout a vast array of different
disciplines people running into the same
concept of these these two systems in
the brain alright so this is the sort of
what I see is the traditional view of of
emotion in artificial intelligence which
essentially is what herb Simon was
talking about so you have some of the
environment you perceive what's going on
then you have your cognitive systems
that are reasoning about the the
environment what's happening so you know
you're playing chess and you're figuring
out where all the chess pieces are and
how you're gonna move them and so on and
then you that drives you to take some
action and then your emotions or things
that are happening kind of on the side
after the fact so after you sorted out
everything that's going on in the world
then you figure out what emotion you
should be feeling and then you sort of
have that emotion and that can modify
how you're thinking about the the task
that you're doing so really a cognitive
machine disrupted by by emotion and
again these disruptions that the emotion
causes may be useful right they may be
actually pointing you in a direction
that may be useful to go but really they
are take second place to this this sort
of higher level cognitive reasoning
engine
the theory that I'm going to describe
today really reverses these two systems
and I think puts the affective
processing system as the thing that has
the first kick at the can so to speak
right so these perceptions come in they
go straight into our affective reasoning
engine this generates an immediate
action this is what I should do next
okay and the key behind this affective
reasoning engine is that it provides an
action a course of action to take which
is the one that is most socially
reasonable in the situation after that
if this breaks down then people can call
in these higher level cognitive
processes in order to figure out you
know how to fix this right so okay so so
that's the sort of very high level view
this is an emotional machine which is
disrupted by cognition yeah - so this
this so I guess there's actually a third
system here which I'm not putting in
which which kind of bypasses all of this
right so you could draw another arrow
that is just immediate so that's when if
I jump at you and you jump back that's
your your sort of instinctive muscle
memory to avoid things coming at you for
example that's not what this is talking
about here this is still a cognitive
process and the theory that I'll
describe to you is this the this
cognitive process relies heavily on on
language so on how we interpret the
world in terms of of symbols essentially
right or you know linguistic concepts
okay any other thoughts or questions
okay so I'm gonna now describe to you
this theory and then I'll give you a few
examples of how I've gotten it working
in a couple of different contexts so how
we're gonna do this is I'm gonna look
back at this work by Osgood in the 50s
so Charles Osgood was a psychologist who
did these amazing experiments and he
went around the world and asked people
to rate concepts
so basically words in the language but
he did this in many different cultures
so different languages and he got people
to rate them on what are called semantic
differential scales and semantic
differential scales are just a scale
with two opposing words at each end
right so angular 2 round it or week two
straw in a rough to smooth right and he
asked people he'd give them a word like
in this case the word polite and say put
a check mark on each of these scales
where you think politeness sits okay and
what's amazing is that there's this
incredible degree of consistency amongst
humans that share the same language that
are in the same cultural group as to
where these words should go so this
picture shows something one of the
diagrams from his study in 1952 showing
two groups of 20 people this is the mean
of two groups of 20 people and you can
see this amazing degree of consistency
everybody agrees right so what's amazing
about that is that if you look at the
word polite and you look at some of
these scales so you might wonder well
what does politeness have to do with
being rough or being smooth right like
it seems to be unrelated in some way at
least on a sort of semantic level but
everybody agrees yeah politeness is more
sort of smooth than rough right so
there's something really interesting
going on here that everybody has this
implicit that we all share these ratings
of things on these different scales so
what he did was they did these studies
and he actually used many more dimension
than this so there was I think on the
order of like a hundred and fifty
dimensions that he used so 150 of these
scales and then he went back and did a
dimensionality reduction and found that
he could account for over 80% of the
variance and all this data with just
three dimensions okay and the three
dimensions are one dimension of
evaluations good to bad one dimension of
power so strong too weak and one
dimension of activity so sort of hyper
two asleep and I I'm gonna put this one
coming out of the board so bigger things
are more hyper and so when you get
people to rate words they all agree on
where they should go in this
three-dimensional space so for example
being polite is good and kind of
powerful and being abusive is sort of
weak and bad and really active right so
this is a bigger word and being serene
is good and kind of weak and really
inactive and you can do the same thing
with identities so students and
professors for example is a good there's
a good example so students or everybody
kind of agrees that students are our
students and professors are about the
same goodness right but maybe professors
are a little bit more powerful than
students and students are maybe a bit
more active than professors right and
this is culturally dependent right so if
you go to Japan for instance then
professors are typically seen as
significantly more powerful than
students right so but if you come to
North America then this has sort of
become normalized students and
professors are seen as much more equal
on this power to mention and behaviors
as well so apologizing to somebody and
fighting with somebody and so on so this
is actually real data taken from a study
done in 2003 in the United States so
these are the means of put the words
that the means of where people would
rate these concepts again I'll just
reiterate that the important thing to
remember here is that everybody in the
culturally in the cultural group agrees
on where these words should go in this
three-dimensional space
okay so how we're gonna take this this
idea and leverage it and turn it into a
control principle that we can use to
drive an artificial agent and we're
going to do that using this a fact
control theory and what effect control
theory says is that people carry around
these fundamental sentiments okay the
fundamental sentiments are these things
here this is everybody's agreement on
where things should go in this very
simple just three-dimensional space when
a social action occurs so something
happens in the world so for example
maybe in this case here we have a nurse
and here's a nurse for dumping some
water on this guy's head and here's a
nurse helping this this lady for example
these social actions create what are
called transient impressions so the
transient impressions are also
culturally shared things they are how
you feel about the situation so how you
feel about these things in context all
right and the transient impressions may
be different from these fundamental
sentiments and the difference is called
the deflection in this theory and the
effect control principle says that
people try to experience events that
confirm fundamental sentiments so
essentially they try to reduce this
deflection so effect control theory is a
consistency theory it says that we will
try people will basically do the thing
that sort of leads them to situations
where things are emotionally consistent
and the consistency is defined by a
culturally shared construct which I'll
show you in a sec yeah so any okay so
I'm going to go through a couple of
levels of sort of increasing detail of
this this theory and this is sort of at
the the highest the highest possible
level but interrupt me any time if you
have questions as we go but I'll show
you a bit more detail of this as we go
along it's all described in this really
nice book by David hi so who's the I
guess the guy who's done
many many years of work on this theory
starting from the work of always good
and many others as well and described in
this really nice little book called
expressive order one of the interesting
things about this book is that it comes
it sort of has two parts the first part
is all the social psychological part and
it's just you know it's text and it
describes his work in in looking at a
variety of different cultural groups and
and how they follow these kinds of
dynamics and then the second part is as
a mathematical model okay and what's
sort of interesting is when you talk to
most sociologists they've sort of all
read the first part of the book but come
kind of ignored the second part so they
you know they don't tend to be math
amend to have that sort of math
background and when I read it I read the
first part of the book and that was like
completely lost and no idea was going on
but then I read the second part I was
like oh this makes total sense right so
this is why it's good to have a
multidisciplinary group working together
alright so here's a little bit more
detail affect control theory uses a very
simple grammar of an actor behaving on
an object the object is often another
another person right people have these
fundamental sentiments about each of
these three things right so this is a
nine dimensional vector and it's
according to the theory these vectors
lie in the range minus four point three
to plus four point three and I've asked
every sociologist I've met who works in
this theory of why it's four point three
and nobody seems to know I think it's
lost in the sands of time but it does
have something to do with Osgood's
original experiment it's actually not
important and the versions that I work
with is not restricted to be in this
range and you could rescale it to be
anything you wanted okay when you see an
actor behaving on an object it creates a
transient impression for each of them as
well and this is again gives you a nine
dimensional vector in the same space the
predictions of the transients from the
fundamentals are given by this nonlinear
operator which I'll show you in a second
and this is something that is also
culturally shared everybody agrees on
how these if these impressions are
created the deflection is then just the
Euclidean distance between fundamentals
and
transients and the effect control people
principle says that actors work to
reduce this deflection alright so you
can use this as a control principle
because you can say part of this these
sentiments is a behavior so you can say
what is the best behavior to take in
order to make this actor and this object
agrees sort of emotionally to be doing
something emotionally that's consistent
okay so you can use this deflection
measure as an optimization service that
you can walk down to find the optimal
behavior to take effect control theory
also has a very precise definition of a
motion which is remarkable this is I
think the only theory I've ever seen it
has such a precise definition the
emotions are described as being
proportional to the vector difference
between fundamentals and transients and
people use emotions as a communicative
signal to tell the person that they're
interacting with where that person is
getting it wrong right so if I'm
interacting with you and you're not
treating me how I think I should be
treated in this situation I'll send you
an emotional signal in order to help you
correct for that and so that we can come
to an agreement on how we're supposed to
be behaving yeah it's a vector in the
same three-dimensional space
are these points yeah there would be a
point in the space yeah and if you look
back at here that's why these emotion
words are in the same space right so the
nice thing about this three-dimensional
space is that you can compare all these
different entities in the same space so
behaviors identities emotions they're
all comparable directly right with a
simple three dimensional vector okay all
right so here's the little bit more
detail so we have a social interaction
happening here here's our nurse and our
patient we've already done a population
survey so we've asked people what do you
feel about a nurse okay and we've
gathered a rating for nurses which is
this one here so nurses are seen as two
point nine one point five zero point two
for example and then we've asked them
about patients and patients are a little
bit less good much less powerful and
much less active and how about
comforting the behavior of comforting
well that's positive and powerful and
not very active right given these
fundamental sentiments we compute a
transient impression for each of the
three and the transient impression is
given by a series of equations with
polynomial features in them so the
polynomials are basically these
polynomial features are combinations of
these different elements in the
fundamental sentiment okay so this one
here is the evaluation of the behavior
multiplied by the evaluation of the
object and then it has a positive
coefficient and that's the effect on the
evaluation of the actor right so what
this term says is that if the actor does
something good to a good person then
they will seem more good right these
coefficients are things that are also
culturally shared and measurable so we
can ask people how do you feel about a
nurse how do you feel about a patient
how do you feel about the act of
comforting how do you feel about a nurse
when you see a nurse comforting a
patient okay and that measures
this transient impression and then they
can do a regression and find these
coefficients and find that they are
again shared culturally all right so the
difference between these two things is
the deflection and like I said before I
can use that to predict the next
behavior so I can optimize over this
deflection measure in order to compute
the best behavior to take I can also
compute a reaiiy denta fication of the
nurse and the patient so I can say if I
see somebody comforting a patient who
might that be
Wow well that's probably a nurse right
so I can do that as well okay before we
go to an example which might help
clarify some of this any questions all
right so let's walk through an example
we'll use this nurse patient example
here is our nurse and our patient again
here is their 3 D evaluation potency and
activity fundamental sentiments and
remember these are culturally shared
I'll just keep reiterating that so we're
sure we remember it the nurse is up here
and the patient is here the important
thing is that the nurse knows that she
is here and knows that the patient is
here and the patient knows that she's
here knows that the nurse is here ok
they both agree on that so I can compute
well let's see what happens if the nurse
comforts the patient right so I compute
the transient impressions which are in
light blue and you can see they're quite
close to the fundamental sentiments and
then I can compute what emotions would
be felt and communicated the nurse who
comforts the patient would feel
compassionate and the patient would feel
serene okay and the deflection is low is
a 1.3 so that's a low deflection but
let's say we make the nurse ignore the
patient right so here's a nurse who's
ignoring a patient ignoring is is quite
negative and not very powerful now the
nurse seems much more bad than a normal
nurse would seem right we'd say well
who's this this is not a very nice
she's ignoring this poor patient right
but the patient also seems more bad
because well maybe this patients been a
really nasty patient right and that's
why the nurse is ignoring her
so we construct all of these things but
we do so just by computing these
transient impressions it's a very simple
calculation the emotions that would be
created or agitation for the nurse and
indignant the patient feels indignant
how dare you ignore me I'm the patient
right this these are the remember these
are the signals that one that each would
send to the other in order to correct
for this so the patient would send this
vector to the nurse and say to the nurse
essentially by sending that emotional
signal which humans can do very very
quickly
hey listen I'm supposed to be up here
and you're treating me like I'm down
here so and I'm telling you exactly how
you're treating me by sending you this
vector and the nurse can take that and
say oh right I've got it wrong I thought
you were you know horrible patient but
really you're not right so I'll correct
for that and do something to make it
better
deflections hi
yeah so okay what it means on the county
on the behavior is that you may be
interpreted at the behaviors right so if
your team is happening then you're like
me I'm sure that's a nurse and I'm sure
that's a patient maybe she's not
ignoring the patient right people are
you seek a an interpretation of the
situation that makes it emotionally
consistent right so the transient
impression would be one way of getting
that from the from the behavior right so
for example this this is gone what you
can see here is this is going up in
evaluation right and it's going up in
power so one possible so that's saying
well maybe this is not I don't know what
word would be close to this transient
impression but it's probably something
less like ignoring it's nothing more
positive right well maybe she's busy and
just will come back to this patient
later or something like that that make
sense
alright here's another example this is a
student and a automated tutor so this is
one of the early examples that we built
with this theory and the student and the
tutor are this is kind of like student
and professor right they're kind of in
the same spot but maybe the tutor has a
bit of power over the over the student
so we can compute well what would a
student do to to a professor well the
student would do something like this
EP and a rating and I can look up in my
dictionary of sentiments that I've had
rated by people and find this behavior
well that student might ask something to
the tutor and then the deflection is low
the transients are close to the
fundamentals and everything's good
what if this the tutor yells at the
student okay this creates transient
impressions that are very far from these
fundamentals so this well maybe this
student is really you know a lot more
less a bad student or no but there's a
horrible tutor right and then the the
the obvious of what emotion would be
felt well maybe this tutor is angry and
this student would be exasperated or
remorseful then we can compute well what
would the student do in order to try to
correct for this situation well they
would maybe listen to the to the tutor
and feel self-conscious and this act by
the student would help it to restore his
fundamentals transient impressions back
towards his fundamental sentiments but
not so much for the tutor because the
jury's still out the student doesn't
know maybe this tutor is really a nasty
tutor after all but if the tutor then
does something so this is the the
computation the optimization for the
deflection so it's minimizing this
deflection well what would the tutor do
something like apologize to the student
and now they've sort of managed to get
back to somewhere where the deflection
is fairly low okay so what I did here in
this example was I forced the tutor to
yell at the student that's not an action
that effect control theory would compute
because it creates so much deflection
right so I create that artificial action
and
and compute what's the optimal thing for
the student to do to try to fix things
and then what's the optimal thing for
the tutor to do to try to fix things
even more
yeah it could there could be
circumstances where it's appropriate
yeah and people would could yell at each
other for a variety of different reasons
one of them is maybe not yelling at
maybe that's not that's too a little bit
too strong yeah one of the things that
happens when deflection goes up is that
this system too thinking kicks in right
so when there is a inconsistency on the
emotional so if the basic idea is that
if I'm operating this is sort of like an
equilibrium theory right so if we're on
the same page and we're operating
according to this emotional model as
long as everything stays at that
equilibrium point then we'll just keep
doing that right it's really easy you
don't have to think you just have to
operate in this simple three dimensional
space as soon as things go off the rails
though then you kick in this higher
level cognitive reasoning right and one
of the things that that that might help
with is that it might force the student
to actually think about what they're
learning for example right and then
they'd actually consider it and take the
information in instead of sort of just
ignoring it and pretending like
everything's fine so that could be one
reason yeah you just said does that sort
of is there an implication maybe that
you
some shared the scenarios it has there's
utility and having high deflection
because it forces you to engage the
higher level system and start thinking
yes no no there could be for sure yeah
and I'll talk about that bit more in a
second but effect control theory doesn't
have a utility function right the
version that I've developed which I'll
show you next does but a fat control
theory is only describing what's
happening at that equilibrium point
right so let's talk about utility again
after I show you Bayes act right right
yeah yeah that's that's but a student
staring at the window is not being a
very good student right so they're
already off the off the mat off the you
know the equal that equilibrium point
right is there a circumstance where yes
I'm you know I try to think of a good
example there but
yeah we're just looking at yells at and
I'll bring to you like lower left
quadrant so the student was in like the
upper right yeah the this this like
going getting a transient that is here
from here is only based on this point so
if the student was actually up here then
yelling at wouldn't necessarily bring
them in the same spot right so so but
you're right it could be something along
those lines right maybe a better example
is the the work that's done in cognitive
therapies for depression so a depressed
person is someone who has a very
negative sense of who they are right so
they feel kind of negatively about
themselves and for many years people
thought that the way to handle this was
to blast the person with positive
positive thoughts right and that doesn't
work very well and the reason it doesn't
work very well is because you're not
treating the depressed person like a
depressed person that's how they think
they are right and so you have to so the
self verification theory came along and
said that well what you need to do is
agree with the person that the world is
terrible and that everything sucks and
and then you say yes this is the way you
are I'm I am verifying your your sense
of who you are as a depressed person
right so I'm performing negative actions
but I'm doing it in a way in order to
get us basically at that point of
emotional alignment and then from there
I'm gonna slowly try to work you in a
direction where you hopefully become
less depressed for example
that make sense okay all right so my
work in in this has been to develop so a
version that adds a couple of new pieces
to this one is a utility function and
the other one is modeling identities and
behaviors as probability distributions
right so of course it's not the case
that everybody does agree exactly on
where these concepts sit in this
three-dimensional space so when you make
these measurements you actually get a
fairly big variance around the mean so
everybody does agree on the mean but
there's a lot of disagreement on where
they would go okay and this various
turns out to be very very important so
it's something that people I believe use
in order to handle operation operating
in groups right so the problem with
group behavior is that everybody's
different there's this diversity right
we aren't even if you're in a single
cultural group so we as academics are
often in groups that involve many
different cultures but even if we're in
a very uniform cultural group there's
all sorts of differences because people
are interacting with each other in many
different circles and it's sort of maybe
in a small world type type social
network because of that there's lots of
uncertainty that comes into play and we
need to be able to model that
uncertainty in order to in order to use
this kind of idea this emotional
consistency to cooperate with other
people okay so those are the two pieces
and I'll walk you through how this works
as well I have to have quite a few
number of papers on it but two of the
journal papers one in artificial
intelligence the other one as Luke
pointed out in the american sociological
review in this paper won two awards at
the aasa' meetings in in 2016
all right so the model is based on a
partially observable Markov decision
process or give you how what this is all
about and then we'll see how we can fit
this effect control theory piece on to a
generic model of how an agent
interacting with the world so a pom DP
or partially observable Markov decision
process consists of a
set of states X and a set of
observations that we can make about
those states so these are unobservable
or latent states a set of observations
we have an observation function which is
the probability distribution relating
these two things there is a set of
actions that an agent can take that
change the world according to some
transition function which is another
probability distribution and then we
have some reward or utility function
that describes the agent's preferences
over these states using a numeric scale
okay so that's the generic model and you
can use this view a number of different
things and that may be the simplest way
of visualizing how you can use a pom DP
to generate a plan is to just do a very
very simple forward search right general
this doesn't work but this is a way of
describing what you actually are trying
to do so here we are in our current
state and remember this state since this
X our sort of interpretation of the
world is latent we can't observe it
directly then the state that we're in is
actually a belief state so this is a
probability distribution over all
possible states from this state my agent
has a number of different actions that
it can take which lead it to another
belief state after taking the action and
then the other person that the agents
interacting with has a bunch of things
that it can do and that leads to another
state and so on and so forth and down
somewhere in this tree is some rewards
let's say and then I can draw this whole
tree out find these rewards and then
propagate them back up through the tree
weighting them by the probability of
these things happening and then I can
use that to rank the actions that my
agent has and pick the one that
optimizes it over the utility function
so that's just basic Bayesian decision
all right so what's the problem with
doing this of course is this tree you
can't write it out it's way too big and
these branching factors are colossal
right and so if you tried to do this
you'd rapidly run into major problems
and a lot of the work in reinforcement
learning and decision theory is how do
you expand this tree in a smart way so
that you don't wind up having to to draw
the whole thing out so for example you
can do things like say well as far as
what the other person is gonna do I'm
just going to ignore all the things that
are really unlikely okay that could
reduce the branching factor here by
doing that but this branching factor is
much harder to handle because I can't
ignore any action that I have available
to me and the reason is if I ignore one
action it could be that that is the
action that leads to an infinitely
higher reward than anything I've seen
before right and so that's the
reinforcement running problem I've got
to try them all if I don't I might miss
the one that is gonna be you know utopia
all right so now we're gonna put in this
social and emotional reasoning engine
and see how we can use that to help us
guide that action selection right
remember back to the start of the talk
we talked about this emotional reasoning
engine is gonna sort of tell us roughly
what to do in order to get by right and
we're gonna do a bunch of maybe
cognitive calculations after that too to
help us out
so I'm gonna take my basic palm DP and
I'm gonna just make a slight
modification in order to make the
presentation a little bit easier I'm
gonna add a random variable that
describes my own action all right I'll
call this B Prime and it's just
deterministically set by a okay so this
is no change at all in the model I'm
just adding this this one random
variable and then I'm gonna layer in a
set of random variables one for
fundamentals and one for transience and
I'm going to connect them through time
okay so the transients are going to
evolve through time according to this
impression formation equation so let's
say well what do I expect
the transient impressions to be after I
see an event taking place the
fundamental sentiments will evolve
through time as well I will admit the
fact that these fundamentals may be
changing slightly so if I for example go
and start living in a different culture
then I need to sort of shift to my
fundamental sentiments a little bit so
I'll admit that maybe happening then I
have this red link between the two which
is my effect control principle it says
that I believe that fundamentals and
transients will be close together and
then I have these green links which are
my shared cultural sentiments about
things so essentially saying that things
in the world have fundamental sentiments
okay and that's another probability
distribution and that can take into
account the variance in these
fundamental sentiments so given all that
I can combine them together and compute
a probability distribution over
fundamentals given all of these things
and then I can integrate out the
identities and create a distribution
just over the behaviors in this three
dimensional space okay this probability
distribution I've actually labeled as pi
because it's a policy in a way it tells
me what to do next this is a probability
distribution in ep and a space but it's
telling me this is the emotional
signature of the thing to do next in
this situation right as a probability
distribution so then I can draw a sample
from this and that's the thing I should
do next
right or or I can seek the maximum or
something like that
that makes sense okay all right so how
does this help us well essentially from
a belief state it tells us this function
here says well you know what you don't
have to actually consider every possible
action you should consider actions only
that have this this emotional signature
right because those are the ones that
make sense to the people that you're
interacting with there's a socially
acceptable behavior that you should be
taking so the way I imagine this is that
imagine this huge tree is in the dark
which it is right because we can't we
can't draw the whole thing out and this
effect of reasoning engine is like
shining a beam of light down through
this tree okay so it's saying these are
the things you should consider next
don't even think about these things over
here right so it's an intentional
mechanism it's not a way of ranking all
of the actions it's a way of saying if I
draw a sample from this distribution I'm
going to get something that's in this
flashlight beam and the things in this
flashlight beam were the things that are
going to work at this emotional
consistency level okay so essentially
this is a way of solving this problem by
having this shared cultural information
on the side that we're using in order to
guide to guide attention okay this this
same idea actually comes you see it in
another branch of sociology called
practice theory which is sort of it's
fairly far removed it seems from effect
control theory or at least the
practitioners of these theories would
would say so but what's remarkable is
that board use may be one of the big
sort of originators or thinkers in
practice theory described something
called the habitus which is very very
similar to what this is doing so I'll
just read you this quote responses of
the habitus may be accompanied by a
strategic calculation but these
calculations are first defined without
any calculation in relation to objective
potentialities
immediately ascribed in the present
things to do or not to do things to say
or not to say okay so those immediate
those objective potentialities or we can
describe them mathematically using this
effect control theory okay and what he's
describing this strategic calculation is
that this flashlight beam is not just
illuminating a single action it may be
illuminating just a couple of actions
right and within the flashlight beam I
can then use my cognitive reasoning
processes in order to try to find what
is the best actual action to take
in order to optimize over this utility
function right so this we get back to
the utility function that you were
asking about earlier I'm still gonna try
and optimize this right but I'm only
gonna do so within this subset of these
branches of the tree all right
so the idea is that the humans will only
do this if they have time right time is
an important thing if time runs out I've
got to act then I'll just do the thing
that's most emotionally consistent if I
have time to sort of think about a
little bit then I'll wind up maybe
finding something that benefits me a
little bit more right people that that
do too much of this tend to sort of
throw things into disarray in social
situations but that's it goes very much
in line with what Buddha was talking
about I believe okay so that's a that's
all that's sort of the model
presentation that I'll give and I'll
walk through a couple of examples
actually I'm already at almost at a time
so I might just go through the first one
and then briefly the second one but any
questions about the model
yeah just going back to the original
sort of three-dimensional
embeddings let's say of words
they see how many how much coverage of
like the Lex there
like how many words have one of these
associated three
so there's a number of different
basically depends on how much you money
you want to spend on your study right
but the sociologists have gathered large
dictionaries so the most recent one that
was gathered has I think 800 or
somewhere somewhere around 800 identity
words and 800 behavior words and they're
rated by on the order of 50 individuals
each one so you have a pretty good
sample of how people feel about it yeah
so those those dictionaries exist
there's also bigger emotional
dictionaries that are on the order of
maybe or 10,000 words or something like
that but not gathered by these same
after control theorists so
embeddings - what we use more regularly
with word
emotional language modeling yeah yeah so
we actually so I've had a few students
work on that problem and I know a few
people who are working on it so exactly
that that ideas that would take a take a
word embeddings model and somehow also
integrate this it may be the case that
if I construct a let's say a three
hundred dimensional word embedding that
these three dimensions of EPMA are in
there somewhere right and and so it's
not altogether clear that that is
happening though because you you wind up
with like the movie board and betting
strained on the movie ratings for
instance you get the word good and bad
or really close together right because
they are used in very similar contests
yeah that's right yeah so I'm not I'm
not clear on on that yet but right yeah
party blanking the terminology you using
the kind of the initial emotional
effects of better than this two
dimensional space are are are not
dependent on these relationships right
there's just a word for two there that's
right
so have you thought about how to
do this or think about this in the
context of those changing relationships
yeah so I mean that is a theory so by
the concept is that I want to say I woke
up in the hospital and I see a guy you
know a person in a white lab coat right
I will have a sort of my cognitive
process will say oh doctor
right this is a doctor and then I'll
associate an emotional fundamental
sentiment with doctors right this is how
I believe doctors are and then using
that I'll compute what I think this
doctor will probably do to me right but
that concept that fundamental sentiment
is going to be the same in any context
right so if I see a doctor when I'm
taking the subway then I'll be it'll
still be doctor but then it'll be doctor
on the subway right and so that
additional context I can put in as well
and that context would change things
further
so let me reiterate that when I
described a CT remember we just had this
three dimensional this three dimensional
grammar of actors behaving on objects so
I can augment that and then this has
been done with a fourth thing which is
the setting or the context right so I
can say actor behaving on object in some
setting right so student joking with
professor in the classroom is different
than student joking with professor in
the bar right
because it because it's changing over
time I mean just listening a single
clanging you can bet the entire state
within this context but that seems much
more difficult to do then you just have
the relationship the you know the
emotional content be able to change over
time yeah so the tricky thing is that
the the the state of the MVP right this
underlying denotative state this X
becomes is very can be very high
dimensional right this this element here
can get really complicated okay
but the key thing is that these pieces
here always stay the same they're always
in this three-dimensional space and
they're comparable within that
three-dimensional space right so I don't
have to model all of this context if I
can just get this emotional meaning of
things so I can compute a whole bunch of
things just with the emotional meaning
without having to figure out how the
world works right okay so I think I'm
out of time so I sort of I think it gave
this much more slowly than I usually do
but that's - what do you want me to do
should i okay okay
I'll skip this prisoner's dilemma stuff
but this is sort of a canonical of the
sort of minimal working example of using
this theory in practice and I can
actually show you a demo of this game
play if you'd like after the fact and
I'll describe the the other piece that I
wanted to mention was the famous COG
project there's a project that's in
collaboration with my calling to be a
Schroeder who was the guy who introduced
me to a fat control theory and he's in
Germany at the Potsdam University of
Applied Sciences Kim Rogers who's a
sociology at Dartmouth College and main
a gapan who's a software engineer
with me so this is funded by this
transatlantic platform digging in a data
challenge and what we look at here is
we're looking at interactions of people
on online collaborative networks like
github for example so that's our primary
sort of target so we look at people
interacting over you know pieces of code
on github and then we're really
interested to find out how do these
social and emotional factors come into
play when people are trying to actually
do something together in a social
network so I won't give too many details
about that so maybe I'll just skip these
last bits and this is or this is the
effect control theory version of the
group simulator so I can create a
instead of just doing an interaction
between two agents I can do an
interaction between a whole group of
agents and then the blue agent is the
sort of everybody's concept of the group
as a whole and I can use effect control
theory to compute not only what people
will do to one another but who they will
do it to all right and the basic idea is
that people will try to interact with
other people that are going to help them
sort of confirm their sense of self the
most so we can do some pretty
interesting group simulations with this
then we've gathered some data sets as
well so a few data sets of that we have
a new data set of these ratings of
actually github concepts so we're
interested in trying to find out how to
developers on github rate concepts on
github so for instance the word commit
means something different to a developer
than it does to someone agreeing to be
married let's say and these were rated
by 50 github developers and then we've
done some work on trying to do some
sentiment analysis so based on pull
requests comments on github can we
extract these three-dimensional vectors
from that and then we have a few other
data sets as well that I've been that
I've been working with so the basic idea
here of this project is we're going to
have all this data coming in we're going
to use some NLP to try to uncover what's
going on but we're gonna guide that
using this app that control theory and
hope
the two things meet in the middle and
then that will allow us to analyze these
different biases that are present in
these social networks and possibly also
allow us to design interventions and
then artificial agents that act in the
networks in order to help the groups
become more more effective or have fewer
biases for example okay so just to sum
up a lot of artificial intelligence is
sort of I believe sort of equated
intelligence with with decision
theoretic rationality but we really know
that emotions are necessary for
intelligence and this low road gives
heuristic social intelligence and that
social intelligence allows us to solve
social dilemmas like the tragedy of the
Commons for example AI may be sort of
pure desert traditionally I people might
say well you know this is just the
reason that we have these emotions as
humans is just because we're so dumb
right there we just need to have bigger
brains and that we could do everything
decision theoretically and we'd be we'd
be all set so I think that that's
fundamentally incorrect and one of the
ways to see this is by looking at the
different forms of commitment that
people make to one another and this book
by Lawler describes these commitments as
being instrumental so these are things
that are just have to do with the sort
of practical things like you know if I
find you to create a coffee and I'm in a
new town that I i I just want to pay
money to a coffee shop and get my coffee
I don't care which coffee shop it is if
one coffee shop shuts down I don't care
I'll just go to the next one but as soon
as I walk into one coffee shop and I
have a little interaction with the
barista then my instrumental commitment
turns into an effective commitment okay
so now I like that's my barista I like
that guy he likes me next time I go to
the same two coffee shops I'd be like oh
yeah I want to go to that one and then
if that one shuts down I'm like oh no oh
my heart is broken my favorite barista
is gone okay these affective commitments
are much stronger much longer lasting
and run much deeper they're really what
motivates humans to interact with one
another so they strengthen the bonds
that make them longer-lasting they also
increase trust between a
and this leads to agents being able to
you know interact with one another using
shorter contracts right I trust this guy
so I'm gonna do what he says that allows
agent to be more efficient and I think
this is regardless of the available
cognitive resources right so a group
that interacts using this is always
going to do better than one that doesn't
okay so that's the end of it so I know
lunch is probably almost here if I
already here but are there any quick
questions like four minutes for Jesse
Christmas so so jesse has some free time
on a schedule this afternoon between
1:00 and 3:00 so if you do want to you
know book book some time to chat offline
you talk to me talk to him we can figure
that home great thanks so much all right